oh beh ragazzi dopo non è neanche
passato un mese da quando è uscito
signor tv sono passate solo due
settimane solo che mi ci sto chiudendo
come un maniaco ho fatto un sacco di
partito giocato non solo con pietro
giocato con i miei amici ho appurato che
le cose più assurde più divertenti
succedono quando siamo in quattro e oggi
siamo in quattro
buona visione girati guarda mi va bene
pareva che bruca rabah madjer ma come
fai a vederla basa su una donna
ragazzi siete due donne splendide a
mettere i baffi che manco di vaio
veramente no ho una visione che non mi
dispiace molto però in questo momento
potrei anche il vedere mettiti ma
veramente
ma tranquilli no problem
non ce la faccio girare enuncia
panchayat sono caduto giù sono che avuto
già aspettato aspettate
aspettate ok sono aggrappati e culo
aveva troppi buchi ovviamente davvero
che la caduta si è fatto porical h che
usati eravamo il propri intenti a vedere
le cose perché per lei quest'isola o
rega luce una bottiglia è messo la nota
le scorte del gioioso grog ma mi adatto
raccolgo il messaggio in bottiglia che
c'è qualche cosa c'è scritto su carlon
cobb stando alle dicerie e nascosto
qualcosa che fa compiere folli quindi
cannon comando della canicola password
del canale di pietro
la gente adesso proverà il canale di
pianosa ma la password che non conosca
valori che non ci arrivo non ci arriva
aiuto non certo andate a cagare e il
covo del ok dove stiamo andando
madonna è la prima visione che ho appena
paolo nella nave e il culo ristorni è la
prima cosa che volevo vede ora il sito
fondo colore devi fare un salto andare
fuori tra nelle loro ma la seconda 20
non funzionare amico ahia ahia
maledizione lo sapevano essere riusciti
pure dove davanti a noi direttamente
come giocatore davanti perso sia
ormeggiata allora mi ama distruggo
ragazzino imbarcando per infiniti
canonical imbarcando hardware canonica
non c'è un ma dov'è la nave nemica come
la vede ragazzi è una nave piccola
quindi possiamo farla fuori diamo via
forza dritto dritto dritto detto stop
rivedo ok andiamo dritti ragali stiamo
per approcciare tra un po è ovvio che
sono fermi ci sta che di buttare banati
hai preparato uno scontro al buio
raga dobbiamo è di girare un po di sera
ci siete tutti pronti sui cannoni
ognuno dovrebbe avere un cannone guai
rega non chiara tutti cercano di tutti
con un cannone 26 pietro pietro
vai vai si stanno si stanno parlando
quelli buy
poi ok sono la tensione io sono andati
giù ragazzi ebrei non aveva più non più
credo che si era andiamo su non avevo
giornale speriamo gela lanciano mettiamo
ancora
forza ragazzi tutti dentro sbarra di
stormi sparami sparami non ha però di
suonare spara spara ai a quanto s'è
andato avanti 9 sul teschio sulla
purtroppo troppo questo non c'è nessuno
però c'è uno in sottocoperta l'ho visto
da lontano
non so dove non c'è no oggi c'è ok io
gli rubò il teschio no preso ma spara al
barile ed esplosive ruba ruba rubare un
premio
prendi glielo premi per l'efficiente ma
li vedete ci sono la soul di seal e sono
sull'isola sull'isola tempo vieni pietro
ruba di lavarmi ora che sono sull'isola
li vede lo stato della gli ha rubato il
teschio intanto lo metto così belle
l'hack è male e proprio re che lo ha
ucciso che vada sulla nostra nave vado
via da ragazzi mi ha ucciso come ti ha
ucciso
sono morto perché raga sulla nostra nave
potrebbe perché non eri tu che stavi
togliendola ancora la nostra nave ma io
penso fosse no a valvole sulla barca non
era nuova ci ha rubato barca non era
dova quello europeo sapevo tranquillo
arriva remaster esponendo porca vacca
maniera nuova quello infatti diceva
qualcuno mi ha sparato non capivo chi ok
torni a braga è andata giù la nave che
avevano vogliano che sparando cavolo
raga io sono sulla nostra nave dove
dovevo dare dal mondo c'è qualcuno
questo punto non so che nessuno no no va
bene in tutto questo cosa è successo si
sono buttati giocoli madama rosy
investendo libero barca va bene ma lei
in tutto questo non avevamo la missione
nato
ecco qual è la missione era cannon con
stanno delle dicerie nascono fare con fa
contiene follie trova la nostra capanno
nato sulle riveste vecchio lupo di mare
con p6 passi a est faccio siamo lontani
da quel posto canon cove a destra perché
allegri clima a sinistra lega sinistra
sto andando e quella l'isola questo
diverso trovi hai trovato una naufraga
abbandonata
no ecco la ama e stola con questo voto 6
non ha pregato non funziona da questo è
un paio di sei più sei molto più
naufrago che naufraga ok dopo un altro
vista naufrago maledizione dovrebbero è
una persona è un individuo è un idea
credo che sia magari una roba non è
nascosta questa magari questa che però è
morta ormai farei faccio un test dai bei
passare un test se i passi dove a s ok
volevo fare vedere se questa 123456
scava schiavo scava schiavo hai visto ha
funzionato però detto che la giusto però
era era era una
è un po magra è una fashion blogger ok
abbiamo visto ha capito che non è finita
un segreto c'è stato confinato su one
the r's rifiuti esiste del loro molto
bramato è presente solo che tesoro non
so forse proprio questa eccolo qua
quando sei ma potreste smettere di fare
no no no è la cosa più brutta che io non
posso filmare quest'anno ma non c è
veramente è la cosa più oscena che io
abbia mai visto non voglio vedere fate
schifo andiamo avanti
quando ero bambino rimettiti a guidare
ma basta non faccio mai fatto bene e
cosa dobbiamo trovare qua non lo so è
che si sta sbloccando l'ha trascritta
aspettato prendere la nota in bottiglia
allora un film una campanella della
vedetta sul punto più a campana
campanella perché piccola campana della
vedetta sul punto più alto dell'isola è
stata narrata una storia che adoro e se
tu non rompe le balle o figli di colpi
tra trasforma il cielo su certi loro
hanno più alto e andare a punto più alto
di dove andare a campare la vendetta è
quel posto lì dove lazio non c'è più
niente né ha trovato una trovata che
sono
guardate in giro spara un colpo ok ok
non è un altro eccoci qua bisogna
tappare la vedetta ok ok si sta
sbloccando l'altro evento che perfetto
basta ragazzi credo delle navi in fondi
fas occhio quando il fondo da una una
crisi allora con tutto questo
no a sud est e saggio sono questi scopi
del suo retaggio servita multi nato a
sud est sud est nord sud ovest est
e forse quel che cerco diventa pietra
tombale si avverte ammutinato del
basilisco per forza maicon trovato un
tesoro a caso ve lo giuro su dio
forse era né il primo né ma ho trovato
un fortissimo non te lo giuro ma che
curò tombale serpente ammutinato cosa è
arrivato sono così no no no questo è un
serpente c'è una tomba di kha ok lo
attivato dalla misera tomba del serpente
ammutinato sull'este dalla metta sei
sempre più vicino cammina su depressione
palme e scava fino a trovare il totale 9
vedono a scavare a casa quelle sono le
palme credo sud dovrebbe essere quello
sud
ok poi intorno rega vice cava trovato
braccia no no è quello è quello che
piange porca vacca porta tra tutti
quelli che piange
iii quarto
e non lo vedevo allora non so se questa
manovra che stiamo facendo da un po ma
funziona funziona praticamente per i
genchi e l'ingegnere qua degli pensate
vi che anche mani eravamo ragazzi come
com'è possibile per ha funzionato 0 col
seno conservato mia è riuscito a girare
una parte amica oggi fai manovra d'oro
io giro a destra come lo re troppo a
iorio
[Applauso]
[Musica]